oh you can do the behind-the-scenes ice
you know what time it is well here on ah
as you hold off on that for now B I mean
when liked amber gets here as I me will
have flippy playing time for that we're
already a little behind slope it because
someone was late oh you're gonna late -
yeah but I was here before here this is
true it's you're taking all the Herod
ice it's not out there and it's a li
right take a look it's yep this is what
we get
oh man until you turn the camera on then
it's like oh wait no no we can't see
that's how filming works with us when we
want the weather to be bad it's suddenly
good we want to be good it's suddenly
bad I just like how let's see last time
I brought my car out here
it got totaled in a rack and I had to
get a new one and the next time I'm out
here to film something with you
yeah it Hales on my new car well you
know it's Hawaii part of my Captain
Planet evil device that changes the
weather to bring destruction to
everybody I'm just saying I think
between you and mother nature you're
both out to kill my car well they did it
they killed my fucking car from Big
Lebowski that kilkis could have lasted
another 10 years they're making a run
for it run run hey
if you meet you yeah it's crazy weather
hi yes I didn't even break a code okay
so I'm from promising I get it smell
good
yeah that's you shit yeah yeah what's
that yeah this is so fun stuff while we
write thing and how it's going I mean we
were gonna keep filming with like Willy
Wonka but there you are you're I'm black
Willy Wonka Wonka would be my favorite
so I mean we we could either try and I
I'd rather wait to see if it goes down a
bit more I'm almost thing it didn't you
want to get much code you know probably
just sweet let's all drive in the
hailstorm yeah I guess you guys did just
come out of that didn't you oh by the
way around welcome to try I just our
time behind the scenes that I've seen
okay do you mind good no I don't care oh
well just gonna say one is the NC video
that the one with the NC team gonna go
up roughly do you know uh it might go up
on Monday if I okay so yeah that this
will be a way before then a way so
that's yeah yeah he shooting it can't be
a real fast for this uh NC thing he's
doing make sure to leave all these
details in your binder so yes I will Oh
with that said uh do we want just trying
to fill that just go ahead get that out
of the way we could I have well I might
want to wait I have like my cello and a
bunch of equipment okay yeah I get that
okay well that's so let's see how
standing in the back day if now we can
just look for the Cashman we're gonna do
he was like you're very not slutty
we're like you're not really like I
don't under age an airing like this
would look adorable you know like that
it's more like just those really hyper
fangirls you see like oh my god was it
incredible I just died over that oh my
gosh water for the hyper of the hyper
nerd girl Oh character so this my
laughing oh yeah like I didn't see this
in the script like most your eyes are
hyper girl I know why I couldn't let you
pointed by like the shot is a very basic
yeah it was on backwards self yeah yeah
yeah I was looking at that I'm like yeah
where did that come from that looks like
something you tires to the important
they came together and Stitch the best
enough it's definitely hipster I don't
know if it's like I'm cattigan isn't
some sort of it's like the clothes are
the only ones see are actually the ones
that we have behind me I love to see the
jean jacket over it's like
yeah you you do some great video work I
saw yeah good music and all that thank
you thank you I also noticed cuz I've
seen some of these videos mm-hmm you
don't monetize your videos only why do I
do what do ya oh maybe the ones I saw
just for some reasons in that ads yeah
camera I was like there's a lot making
money just ahead of which ones you see
noticed like I don't remember just
behind the scenes stuff a hmm cuz I know
I've had to like talk with them a few
times because they said that I was
stealing someone else's work
it was copyright yeah I was like what
this is my it has the automated system
centers caching yeah it's probably
Doug's voice or something they're like
all of us is the nostalgia critic II
can't take this maybe it happened to me
not months ago actually where I was
getting copyright claims for my own
music isn't make any sense it's
ridiculous but yeah it even said you
need written permission from Ron's
guarantee as a song it's like it's like
I promised Ally I need to write a letter
to myself right that's like incentive
David is really weird but yeah but
usually if you didn't get in contact
then like it was like there's a few
emails you can send that can get
everything sorted out yeah I need your
help with that um just in case it ever
happens again yeah yeah I chop it up
pretty well though I leave out like
random stuff like this I'm just like
holding the camera this is gold this is
going in yeah you know it's going in I'm
gonna see this online they'll be like
turmeric Malcolm here probably like the
part like where you're like oh like
whispering just like some random jokes
to me um that day that we were filming
fat grandma I left that in there I
always whisper sweet nothings
no pictures to be we're waiting for the
slash fiction of this to come out he
said that one we're dieting oh I I said
Doug can analyze all night that's not so
much I like analyzing I'd like to
analyzing nobody is a master he is a
master analyst a mastered analyzation is
this going up yes I have no problem if
you like to analyze I'm just saying it's
that Mike you started it you like to
analyze I'm like no I like to analyze
see he did it with the cameras off yeah
my talked about Doug analyze he's like I
gotta turn it back on
yeah cuz it went off you will be
hilarious gonna be hilarious
know what happens in the studio stasis
that's true especially analyzed oh my
goodness
right more hail once it dies down I'll
get my stuff
be a while yeah so like tomorrow
this is it's even twisted be like stuff
won by Robin be huddled in the corner
yeah we come down the stall to cow play
waiting some funny costumes pizza Bell
good acting yes
Brando newest Olivier knew it Harold
Ramis Newland how many weapons you guys
have yeah look at that wall it's like
yeah yeah we had 42 cheese roll they're
really good fake props though I said
they're all free oh right all fake right
great fake fake Chuck now you look like
you yeah the blog's probably wit but
with the vest she kind of looks like an
employee clerks that's have a good well
you know what were those last
want to get a character it's like it's
all the girls that like the monsters
that originally I have them very hipster
haha the Marlin to do I said no they're
not a hipster they're just very much so
just kind of like they're bad girls so
the girls you see a con that dress up
like the American boots you know they're
not like you know are I think it's just
very excitable they're very into
whatever they get into so that's pretty
much what I'm trying to do I'm not
trying to do like a very mean-spirited
one oh I tend to very much like just
sort about funny like those really
excitable bankers or something right
disclaimer photos yeah yeah jinkies it
also looks with the best of looks like
you're really in la-la cuz you can't see
the fear yeah la
the Hales present oh yeah I hope it
doesn't like damage the cars then we got
that to do we're not this is a weird out
waiting huh
we haven't used it for too much else
it's just gone
yay hurry hurry no no the window of
opportunity bicha the sun is shining
bright like I should know it's not too
bad oh yeah it's a good one yeah that's
that's it yeah those are girls we'll see
a cat I think you know that okay so that
one's in the lead just for the heck of
it let's try these are the ones you
never know yeah uh-huh
really like how big is it
Wow have some good hail ya know that's a
really good size it's ring dinos I wish
they really were diamonds though look
how you'd have know yeah that would be
awesome we could pay for the damage to
our car hail fight it just looks like
you're throwing salt at each other no
this is the Lord's probably gonna go
though now has a limit
Thanks oh that was a the geek yeah oh he
was Darla's geek goo goo news I must say
me max fanatics couldn't she in theory
be a cosplayer it's true well it does
look like she's cosplaying as Allison no
awesome if you put this one on
yeah yeah yes he unshowered I've been in
my face with a computer for tough this
is the riot Doug just had a whole
disclaimer saying this was not
mean-spirited and you say that so thanks
all the ones that I thought well I
didn't write this bit and you're the one
putting her in that outfit I'm just
saying what it look like to me you look
like that i I think I even though there
was a body bag bag I don't skate on slow
day well that loves the once-ler is what
the hell it's a once-ler I don't get
this but what's the character from the
more execute no I know but what are the
one slings are there there girls usually
like teenager you know college that are
just love the once where it's like it's
like locate girls I love loci it's like
that again that makes it one more sense
to me than that hipster fuck from the
war axe no no that is the one that's
what I'm talking about
I know but they like him like yeah if
there's a once other secrets that's a
site there was nothing I mean he was
like them he was the douchebag of the
movie for what hanging if you like Zach
rap
oh wow it's really so there's like a
whole following around a huge huge like
I said event the Condor asking like am I
gonna address the one slings that's like
yeah I'm not 900 or bad we we made it
through that but like wow like something
else
yes driving means nothing we're just
saying like it's it all let's go just
feels like I can feel like something
else up here like article yeah yeah like
well did did scars right yeah girl
though right uh is she's like all right
normal though remember we're not being
spirited though no no is she a normal
girl don't like like a very hyper like a
very hyper fangirl um about why in this
non mean-spirited town Terry um once I
think hyper van girls are charming if
you have something against them I've got
nothing against yeah I'm just wondering
why you wrote such a mean spirit eh
based around I think you're just a
mean-spirited person um no just
something where it's
kind of like yeah I mean like she's just
a very hyperactive like you know I love
what you did with that I love it blah
blah blah like just anything she's into
she's gonna be all into it and really
happy I'm really excited it's um I said
the best thing I can think of is kind of
like do you know anything about like the
Loki fangirls at all I know of them made
fun of them too okay for you anything
it's just assistant um one target at a
time day
yeah so fully hate lucky bit will you
okay you've been at conventions were
like there's really hyper and you
playlist and specific specifically
playlist I don't think you've ever been
to playlist live now they're all the
fangirls are till it's a whole nother
level of Fame but they're like oh haha
that's like good news meaning all over
it please include all just miss Malcolm
it does not mean they have you can see
their butts through their shorts oh my
confirmation yeah okay wow this is like
that this is just nerdy yes this is a
different type of yeah this is like I
mean it's the same kind of um okay try
the oh we don't have any done it ones at
all thought we had something
yeah see yes
now she looks pretty Shoshana could get
a word the ones that are really into
like the British scene if you would like
to contact spirited sketch I'll give you
his address its five five five oh good
put your glasses on to expose you did do
I do like the big smile like yeah yeah I
can't believe all the blocks okay super
excited about this Jonas Brothers yeah
listen God take the Hat on just for a
second Jolie Godfather's to you
and now now think of media without that
don't look that bad
Oh God digging that Rob his hat back
I'll wait till Doug's finished he's as a
director he's very indecisive
we'll probably do 20 takes each
different hats different 20 different
hats yeah I think I like that Mo's yeah
that that seems to that's a character
right I think I like that okay character
from Harry Potter this is annoying way
shit she's gonna play it boy later so
yeah we didn't have Malcolm play a woman
what gives yeah it's been a while Rob
Scallon no you hang in there so mmm yeah
oh yeah your video had gone viral that
was awesome thanks yeah yeah 30 songs
yeah 30 songs in 30 seconds
yeah so I'm in it in a minute oh yeah I
didn't do dance things I really wanted
to it was a comment on one of my other
videos they want to see 100 songs in a
minute and I quickly realized that that
wasn't possible
oh stop well with being able to like
recognize the songs right I recognized
that note hey that was totally tight on
me right yeah keep ramping it up like
I'll do another one that's 40 songs in a
minute then maybe 50 60 and then I think
it once I get to the higher speeds I'll
have to just play them way quicker and
then they'll have to be a version of the
video that's like half speeds you can
tell what it is
hmm no hopping Thimphu stand rolling
stone of like your pals your friends
yeah yeah it was really cool and Huff
and actually Outlook or hotmail whatever
I saw on their front page yeah yeah MSN
bought a license from me to use it
nice yes whoa everything Yahoo MSN was
on there too that is so cool it's been
booked it's been fun and Huffington Post
has always been really supportive with
me so good excellent
that's it for the longest time even
within this - Greg Mel PACU it was like
I think they've even still the video
that gets the most views as the 15
presents in 50 seconds yeah like it's
just insane yeah
just like I love my brother the Joker I
know the concrete answer wrong with
these people
ah striking hey she's shimmering and
glowing what oh my god the skin of a
killer sleep don't dreamy he's a
tortured musician that I just want to
cuddle and save he's a completely unique
individual just like everyone else
perfect one more like that he's so
dreamy he's a tortured musician that I
just wanted cuddle and save he's a
completely unique individual just like
everyone else
wonderful are you a tortured musician's
musician would Sam torture me Tokyo
actually crap I'm sure I had you in
flavor once more you totally good
haven't done it oh yeah I wouldn't be
the fast in the fedora
don't you play the guitar huh makes
money just what are you doing this
evening
yeah like yeah so well I see just like
everyone else so yeah so you know I'm
pretty much saying like you know why
would you be into someone who you know
is a nerdy into retro media at a
professional I have grungy look at my
clothes and they look up and you know
we're just gonna play like that cheesy
Roman romance meets of the dum-dum
Gouda so you're just gonna be looking a
little bit like you know maybe for like
three four seconds and just be like what
are you doing tonight
okay uh yeah what are you doing - see
you thing and then I say not you dumper
and we're gonna push the button - sort
of uh you know like delete the connector
you're just gonna be like Oh
like that okay um so yes I mean just
like very me just like this sort of like
swooning head motions or something
ah I think that'll work all right you
ready and action
this is so good oh no gotta give it a
day okay
all right whatever you ready what are
you doing tonight
not you dumper
uh I say on this one yeah the mouthing
no swooning I think the face that does
it all and again just let the mouth guy
hanging open not necessarily yeah like
that
all right you ready uh-huh and action
what are you doing this evening not you
dumper I keep doing almost the hand to
the side like this yeah just like gin up
oh okay yeah yeah so I keep you guys
awake and I say you can hold the face in
the opening for maybe a few second
longer okay all right ready uh-huh
and eyes look a little too crazy this is
what ah bingo and thank you what are you
doing this evening
not you dumper good oh one more um yeah
see you Jeff just like a slight
surprised face like I said just the yeah
hold that face and action
okay well that's an awesome chill it's
like what they played in Tron Legacy
yeah listen I see the Nick Frost guy
just be like ah shit out of cool I got
it from an artist endorsed me recently
so cool
yes see leo is the company amazed G yes
I think I think I might perform yeah
that's like
it's gonna get it closed over there on
the couch now cool
and then you'll be like there hopefully
then just try to be as sweet as you can
oh baby blow what are the front marks by
the way I have no idea with the eye
right here these these taped Oh those
private rooms yeah okay yeah but start
with bowing technique that's the biggest
thing I get is a record cool you want to
try yeah just me so start as soon as I
start making any noise start moving okay
your bowing technique blows did you tape
on those front marks where's your amp I
mean it's an electric cello so why isn't
it plugged up I mean come on you smell
bad babe sorry I'm easily impressionable
yes bad I'll have to sit close to one
it's not that all the way over there
want to do another one just yet cause
I'm looking at your bowing technique
sucks balls what did you paint on the
front marks
is seriously how am I able to hear you
you're not even plugged into an amp
that's clearly an electric cello yeah
you smell bad hey sorry I'm easily
impressionable cuz but I gots it right
next to one really though how are we
able to even hear him playing it's not
plugged in why do you even have us in
this video go over there okay oh love
you babe recording melted I mean just go
like I mean literally
shopping into your the chick at the red
wedding okay I'm yes okay ready Alex if
you want your provides a little bit if
you all those sounds right they do feel
free to okay ready and action
oh yeah mom we're just a protector no we
do like sir like a breathing like it's
early to cannulate
okay let's do one just of the breathing
I really those bees you to the you know
I did you one just like maybe 10 15
seconds of those sounds alright ready
and actually ding hilarious
and this you know boy you know like
you're bleeding and dragging your way
it's just like drag you by your roadside
oh why why why time isn't wait what is
that oh no no not yet just like just
give up you nose like you don't even
give a bell this is why you're going
into the shitter and then people like
jiggle your voice with
Oh
oh that was great hey if you want I can
do this I feel I'm a fellow artist how
do you feel about Tamara's performance
as a tree
dancing is born to be a tree or tree
oh why on set and action why boy why
done this to me wait what is that what
is that on this one when you get to the
wait okay no I mean I guess are like the
big way what is it no no I do you be
enjoying the theme of time together look
at your heart don't you know I I mean
just like yeah this is like your final
plea for life
so yes ivy if you want you provided
that's okay okay ready yes and action
why boy why have you done this to me
wait what is that what is this no
memories we had
oh great I like how it just fades out of
Japan one more for the screen on this
one just you bored yet I'm you just like
printer just like your terror in one
vowel behind-the-scene ception yeah
behind the scenes behind this yes
great job bravo Bravo